everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're gonna be
going over the stafford game but derives
from the petrov defense which is ii 45
and then f3 knight c6 now after Knight
takes on e5 the most common reply from
black is to play d6 and then after the
knight comes back the Knights gonna
capture here on e4 and play continues
but in this Stafford gambit black says
yeah I don't mind that you took this
material right here I'm gonna play
Knight to c6 for this particular video
we are gonna be going over the accepted
line and that is if the knight takes
here on c6 and black recaptures here on
c6 this is the most common variation
that you will see I will do another
video that goes over the decline line if
they choose to do something besides
Knight taking here on c6 now there's a
few options that we're gonna be looking
at today
as far as how white may continue since
the knight is attacking at this pawn
here on e4 the most common response that
I see is 5 this is attacking the Knights
and getting the knight are the pawn out
of harm's way
other moves that you could see are d3
solidifying this pawn chain opening up
for the dark square bishop we get
involved into the game and just all
protects this pawn in the center of the
board and lastly you could see Knight to
c3 pretty common development move
defends this pawn here on e4 as well so
those are the three variations that
we're gonna be going over in the
Stafford gambit so the first move is 'if
I've and that's gonna force the knight
to come up to e4 black really needs to
be aggressive in this game giving up
that pawn this Knight here is attacking
the King side from white also opens up
for both of the bishops to get involved
into the game and this Queen has a
semi-open file as well as can easily
come to Queen to h4 put a lot of
pressure on the King side from white now
White has a few options here the first
one would be to completely ignore this
knight which is easier said than done in
a chess game and that is to play d4 this
is the best move from white control the
center of the board and just let this
Knight hang out here on e4 if they do
this I recommend playing Queen to h4
this puts a lot of pressure on their
opponent and many players are going to
make a mistake here because this is
threatening
Queen to f2 checkmate and a lot of
players when they see this they play
something like g3 to stop that but this
actually opens up the door for a trap
and that Miz the knight coming here to
g3 because if the pawn takes then the
rook is going to fall and if the pawn
takes here then Queen to e4 check and
after the King moves or the bishop or
the Queen let's say Queen to e2 then the
Queen can come up and take here on h1
and whites side is just completely
decimated black should have a pretty
easy game here now if we come back and
say what if the pawn does it come to g3
what if something like III instead this
protects the pawn here on f2 one our
recommend f6
and this is important because black is
gonna be looking to blow up the center
of the board then get the light square
Bishop involved into the game many times
it's gonna come to g4 and then castle on
the Queen side and throw everything they
can at the King side of the board now
white may be looking to kick this night
away can't come to f3 because this pawns
pinned down by the Queen but if you see
something like Bishop to d3 then black
can play Bishop to g4 this is attacking
the Queen and remember the pawn can't
come to a3 which you would like to so
the bishop may have to come back to e2
these are just getting moves from
White's just going back and forth and so
while what black is down upon a material
it does look like he's going to be able
to get some of them momentum back in the
game just from having an active board
state taking material on the center and
then castling on the Queen side of the
board so that's what happens if at the
very beginning your opponent pushes
forward here with d4 next line you may
see from white is to play d3 and it
looks logical looks to kick this night
away and opens up for the dark squared
bishop here but after Bishop to c5 black
is in a really really bad spot they
can't just take this night here on e4
because bishop to f2 is pretty deadly
you can see this is check if the king
takes then the queen is going to fall
right here if the King does not say
maybe it comes to e2 doesn't have any
other options then Bishop to g4 now the
only legal move from white is to take
here on f2 and then the queen is going
to fall so we can already see that it's
not going to work if the pun takes the
night here on e4 but then how else does
it stop this pawn being attacked here on
f2 the only real option is for this
Bishop to come to III but that's not
gonna work as well Bishop takes on e3
and then after the pawn takes here then
Queen to h4 check and things are pretty
bad from here now if we look at and say
Queen to e2 well that's just gonna be
checkmate with Bishop to g4 that's not
gonna work too well
if they try that g3 move well now same
thing as before Knight takes on g3 if
they take with our pawn then the Queen
can just swing up here to h1 that's not
gonna be good for white at all if they
look at this and say the rooks under
attack so maybe I'm gonna bring my rook
here to g1 well now the knight can just
come back here to e4 this is a
discovered attack with the Queen on the
King here but there's also no good moves
from here if it comes to e2 well this is
just gonna be checkmate here on f2 from
the Queen if instead the rook comes to
g2 well now the Queen can come up to H 2
this is threatening taking here on g3 we
still have the bishop can get involved
to the game there's just no good moves
that white has you're definitely going
to lose a ton of material so that's what
happens if they play d3 early on
although it looks like it's gonna be
kicking that night away very early it's
not going to do that because Bishop to
c5 is just deadly the next line you may
see after Knight to e4 is Knight c3 this
is attacking the knight and just says
hey if you want to take material here
White's up upon a material this should
be fine that's not what blacks looking
to do here instead Queen can come to h4
now the slight difference is after the
pawn comes to g3 you
can't just take here on g3 because if
they were to take with their pawn on g3
you can't come to e4 check and fork the
rook here because the Knights just gonna
take here on e4 so we don't have that
option but if you see g3 at this point I
would just recommend taking on c3 if
from here they decide okay well if I
take your queen then you're just gonna
take my queen but I have a king side
that kind of looks really messed up here
if you kind of look at this they may not
look like this setup for white so they
may decide well I'll just go ahead and
take with the pawn here on a c3 well in
this case they took your Knights but now
the Queen's gonna come over to e4 so
this is what we were doing before and at
the end the day this rook is going to
fall so that's gonna be extremely good
for us if they do decide correctly and
decide let's go ahead and take the Queen
here on the H file now that I can take
here on h1 or d1 excuse me after the
king takes now Bishop to c5 you can see
this pawn here on f2 is under attack
there's two pawns on the H file that's
gonna be very difficult to hold on to
those as well the bishop can get
involved here to g4 although black is
down a pawn and material does have a lot
of targets and should easily get that
back in the game so this is not a bad
spot if you do see that they play g3 and
then take your queen right here now we
come back after Queen comes to h4 they
could also play d3 this is gonna be a
huge mistake hopefully you can just see
Queen takes on F - that's gonna be
checkmate that's probably the worst
option but another thing that you could
see is how do they defend this pawn here
on f2 one option would be to play Queen
to f3 and if they do this you have a
couple options one is if you just want
to take here on c3 you have that option
the other option is B to keep material
and just play Knight to c5 yes you are
still down upon a material you have a
very active board state you want to
start getting your other pieces
to the game castle on the queenside is
my recommendation but this is the other
alternative if you see the Queen come to
f3 so that's all that you're gonna see
if your opponent plays this e5 at the
beginning of the game the next variation
is d3 and you'll see this a lot because
players when they see a new opening like
the Stafford gambit they're up in
material and they just want to hold that
advantage as much as possible so this
opens up the door for the dark square
bishop to get involved into the game it
protects this pawn here on e4 it seems
pretty safe but black can get active
pretty quickly with Bishop to c5 now how
does white respond here they have to
realize that there's a strong threat
that's gonna be happening with Knight to
g4 with the threat here on f2 but if
they don't look at that if they play
something like Knight to c3 the Knight
to g4 is pretty brutal there's just no
way to really defend this square here on
earth here if they try something like
Bishop to e3 then the knight can take
here if the pawn takes then Bishop takes
here on e3 and you can see white
standpoint the King side the board's
pretty much blown up here black has that
pawn back in material and they still
have a very active board stage so this
is gonna be good from black standpoint
now if instead they don't play Knight to
c3 if they recognize that the knight can
come up here to g4 and so maybe they
play Bishop down here to g5 this is
pinning down the night so the knight
can't move here but that should not stop
black instead they should get pretty
active and take material here on e4 this
also attacks this Bishop Iran g5 so
that's an important note but it's also
threatening this pawn here on f2 so a
lot of threats that black has here but
you can see that they are giving up
material here on d8 but this would be a
huge mistake it would actually be a mate
threat because if the bishop takes here
on d8 then all of a sudden then black
can spring into action the bishop can
take here on f2 there's no legal moves
except for the King to come to e2 and
then Bishop to g4
and this is
to be checkmate pretty cool checkmate if
you ask me now if they look at that and
say it's gonna be a bad move if I take
the Queen here on the 8th maybe they
just play Bishop to e3 this does stop
the immediate threat here coming to F 2
in this case go ahead and take with your
Bishop here after they take with their
pawn
then you could play Queen to h4 here and
this puts a lot of pressure on them they
are under check right now and there's
not a lot of good moves that they play
King to e2 this is going to be checkmate
right here if instead they play g3 then
same thing as we've seen in the other
variations Knight can take here on g3
this is threatening the Knights here are
the rook here on h1 as soon as the
knight moves it's gonna be a discovered
attack on it the King so this is also
not going to be very good from white now
if we come back instead of bringing the
bishop back here maybe they decide to
take with their pawn well this has the
same challenges as before the bishop can
come here to F to check if they take it
the Queen's gonna take here on d1 and if
they don't if they play Bishop here to e
2 then Bishop to g4 check again pretty
much only half to come to f2 and that's
gonna leave their queen to fall here on
the one all-in-all this is just really
really bad for white so again early on
if they play as we talked about that d3
and the bishop comes here to c5 it's
gonna be a very very good game from
black now the last option is instead of
d3 we're gonna be covering is if you see
Knight to c3 this does immediately
defend at this pawn here on e4 now black
should still be looking to do the exact
same thing and that is Bishop to c5 now
in this case you can see the main
difference with from White's perspective
when they has the night here on f3 they
can always push things like d4 but
because that Knights not here on a3 they
gave it up early on I can't do that
anymore Bishop
to d4 and the queen is protecting it on
d8 so they're not gonna be pushing
forward with their pawn here but instead
you could see Bishop to e2 preparing to
castle on the King side of the board in
this case Queen to d2 this does threaten
the Queen coming here to f2 checkmate so
they're pretty much forced to play
castle on the King side and once they do
that you can just take with your night
here on e4 you got that material back so
both sides are equal in material but
black still has a pretty aggressive
board state so this is gonna be fine for
black if instead they bring their Bishop
a little more active instead of Bishop
d2 maybe it comes to c4 well slight
difference instead of bringing your
queen here to d4 I recommend playing
Knight to g4 and this is still
threatening the same thing the main
difference is if they were to castle on
the King side now the Queen can come to
h4 and this puts a lot of pressure on a
white standpoint more than if the bishop
was back here where you know the bishop
could have taken here on g4 now that the
bishops not on any - it can't threaten
the knight so blacks just has a lot more
variation they can go down if the pawn
comes to h3 well this is not gonna be
good knight takes on f2 if the rook
captures here well then you could just
see the Queen takes on f2 maybe King to
h1 and you can see not a good setup for
whites black has a pretty aggressive
board state can get his life to her
Bishop and bottom to the game casts on
the Queen side start to push all our
pawns toward the King side of the board
this is gonna be very very good for
black now if we come back and say yeah I
don't have to take right here the
Queen's on our attack so maybe the Queen
comes to f3 well now the knight can come
back to h3 and this is double check the
Knights attack in the King as well as
the bishop when the Kings attacks in two
different ways the King has to move
there's no other variation if it comes
to h1 here then you can see Knight to
have to double the attack again only
option has come to
one and then you see the Queen come up
here to H one and this is another
checkmate so you can see there's so many
different traps that white can fall into
in the Stafford gambit and even if they
play perfectly black can maneuver around
and still have a pretty good game now if
white plays flawlessly with any game but
if you're giving up material there is a
way that the other side can overcome
that but I like to play gambits where
you give up a little bit of material
early on but you have so many fighting
chances and if they haven't seen it's
very very difficult for them to play
perfectly so check this out especially
if you play the Petroff defense as black
most of the time they're going to accept
that early on they're going to be taking
the pawn here on e5 I don't see very
many players that are playing this
opening then seeing f6 and doing
anything except taking here on e5 so
you're gonna have lots of different
options to play this Knight to c6 so
check it out let me know what you guys
think about the Stafford gambit again
I'll be doing another video on the
decline line if they choose not to take
here on c6 but most of the time you will
see that thank you guys so much for
watching the video
and I'll see you guys in the next one